I was your son and I'm starting a
business yep what advice would you give
me I would actually look at what you
were into I would know you since you
were my son and I would look at
everything that you're interested in and
the first piece of advice I'd give you
is do something around that for example
let me reverse this on you what do you
love besides business and things that
nature what else are you into karate
great so to me karate would be a very
interesting thing to look at so what
would that be should we start a karate
fashion brand like the way under armor
and Nike role like do you want to go
that route do we want to make karate
content we want to make a little karate
figurine in in Asia and produce it and
sell it on eBay we would reverse
engineer karate we would lay out 10 15
things you could do then I would let you
pick it because I'd want it to be your
decision and then you'd roll